um inhibitions and you know just  lack discipline because it takes  discipline to not get fat and i want  that in a woman i want discipline in a  woman  because if she's overweight like that's  one area of her life she doesn't have  discipline so it probably trickles down  into other areas so she's no i'm serious  it's typically if you don't have  discipline in one area it trickles down  into other areas the same way if a guy  goes to a job and he's a bum that  trickles into other areas of his life so  with her she might not be good at  spending either she might have a ton of  debt she might be sexually promiscuous  like it takes willpower to be the thing  that men want